bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono un po vj e
oggi siamo su aerei
spero che si pronunci così malamente
consigliato in tantissimi non avevo
deciso di farlo inizio perché l'avevano
già fatto in tanti su youtube
ho visto che giravano tanti video quindi
ho detto per essere originale non lo
faccio farò qualcos'altro invece
continuato a consigliarlo allora direi
che posso farlo
sinceramente non sono andato a vedere di
cosa tratta ho visto soltanto un po le
dinamiche come ci si muove però non so
cosa devo fare non so niente allora ci
ritroviamo in mezzo all'acqua subito si
parte benissimo sente un bambino
piangere posto sentendo so io ok c'è un
bambino che piange probabilmente è
l'incubo di tutti i papà che si
svegliano durante la notte perché
bambino vuole biberon
cos'è sta roba non lo so tanto questi i
soliti testi dei giochi oro che non si
caga mai nessuno quindi proseguiamo
siamo partiti già belli fradici quindi
oddio madonna ragazzi questo usain bolt
ok ragazzi il personaggio principale di
questo videogame come avete potuto
notare gli usa in volto perché corre
tipo una formula 1
vabbè questo cosa mi rappresenta spray
paint che cos'era cosa ho fatto
cosa cliccato il tasto si cos'è sta roba
uno spray che cazzo me ne faccio di uno
spray cosa faccio il banda lo faccio ma
si può tipo scrivere si no non ci credo
ok allora ci prova dai prova a fare una
scritta che verrà ricordata nei secoli
ma vj fa vj vediamo
sei un po si capisce vabbè comunque
proseguiamo old cv al moving to cloud
ok perfetto questo l'avevo intuito non
chiedetevi perché ci stiamo andando a
ficcare in sti posti ma è fantastico
allora con l'ambientazione siamo tipo in
una fogna o una roba del genere
vabbè io proseguo anche se non so che
cosa ci faccio qui ma come al solito non
facciamoci domande e proseguiamo
non so bene come come sono i quali sono
i mostri in questo videogame perché non
ho visto però dall'ambientazione so
soltanto che comunque a lungo andare più
o meno così
cos'è sta roba cos'è un test di
matematica
oddio che cazzo è successo
oddio sono sono cadute le pentole e
successo qualcosa ragazzi cè un
fastidioso allarme che è scattato abbia
proseguiamo ben condotti a che c'è
ancora e bambino che piange non ti
preoccupare adesso papa riva darti
biberon
oppure lo spray e meglio magari e spray
al formaggio va beh non importano le
cose che sono state jump l'avevo capito
qual running press cito slide vediamo
che figata
mi sento tipo mirror's edge ok allora al
draft tuta guber you've been a sta roba
serve a segnare dove sei passato wow
allora facciamoci una bella f su tutti i
muri tipo zorro
vabbè proseguiamo sostanza promette bene
un ventilatore bellissimo cosa ci fa
capire che cosa sangue ok perfetto
ragazzi io e laporta non ci entrerò mai
proseguiamo di qua e anche ok ok
cos'è
che cazzo era non si cosi
si sono schiantati dei piccioni sui
vetri
fatemi capire press può finalmente mi
dava fastidio scissione si sono
schiantati dei piccioni sul vetro
ragazzi fantastico ei cos'è qua come una
race non lo faccio meglio io guarda te
ecco adesso adesso c'è quel tocco d'arte
in più vabbè di qua non si può andare
qua dentro spero non mi spunti una testa
ma penso di no vabbè levo entrare però
molto probabilmente in st porta che
promette molto bene va bene sinistro
destra a sinistra penso che si vada da
quei buoni amici che abbiamo incontrato
prima che si sono schiantati sul vetro
quindi andiamo di qua che è chiuso
perfetto allora torniamo indietro
ragazzi siamo costretti andare in mezzo
alla merda perché tanto non nei giochi
oro è sempre così allora
sentono fuori che non mi piacciono
qualcuno ha rubato di potenza
oppure non è qualcuno di pacifico tutto
qua
che è successo è caduta un'altra pentola
oddio non lo so ogni tanto sento dei
rumori strani ragazzi però non è nulla
di promettente questo cos'è quella roba
da giu due non si capisce ma tanto qua
non ci devo andare quindi che me ne
frega ragazzi mi piacciono ambientazioni
perché non sai mai chi sa che cosa cazzo
va incontro e bellissimo topi
insetticida sta roba qua e sia spray che
spari al formaggio che insetticida fa
tutto il bambino e ragazzi il bambino è
vicino e tanto vicino c'è una culla nei
paraggi c'è il beach uno spray c'è odio
questa roba non gatto
cosa ci fa un gatto morto gatto
prigioniero trovato thomas era il gatto
che faceva ma era era un miagolio a me
sembrava un pianto di un bambino ma solo
a me è sembrato il pianto di un bambino
c'era quindi finora era sto gatto morto
che che miagola come fa migliorare un
gatto morto poi me lo spiegate ma vabbè
non ho capito bene cosa è successo ma
evidentemente ho trovato un gatto morto
e qualcosa mi serve ok pipistrelli
pipistrelli pipistrelli pipistrelli ok
voi un pò di spray niente di spaventoso
stiamo tranquilli
ammazza che corridoi lunghi ragazzi ma
dove non andrà a finire si fosse ok
dico
[Musica]
questo è un altro gatto un po cresciuto
però un telecomando
ma no non è un telecomando era una lobby
una chiave una chiave digitale
fantastico c'è qualcuno che piange
perché piangi
cioè io lo spray e basta miccoli e
piantoni sto gioco liga o che bel altro
gatto fantastico non ha senso perché
perché perché i gatti morti perché non
potevano scegliere le farfalle per dire
cos'era store umore una saracinesca
ancora cosa bene altri vetri rotti e non
voglio che mi si schianti qualche altro
piccione sui vetri
preferisco di no ok ragazzi siamo
esattamente nel punto dove prima si
erano schiantati quei cosi esamina non
mi interessa vado avanti perché sennò vi
annoiate se leggo ste cose
find master kg della gdo trovare una
chiave probabilmente che non so quindi
proseguiamo allora di qua no
dove devo andare di qua ci sono arrivato
bene allora devo andare di qua corridoio
lungo c'è del sangue quindi sempre
meglio
perfetto ok
cos'è questo
computer offline per che offline i
computer ragazzi devo controllare
facebook non si fanno anche controllare
facebook esamina niente sarebbe non
serve quindi togliti altro computer
offline questo tipo il mio microfono i
ragazzi sentono rumori veramente brutti
men women women sento tipo non so che
cazzo ma chi cazzo trova aiuto o dietro
cos'è cos'è sto coso ma che è sta roba 7
ott io ci hai un braccio smom co ma
cos'è un ragazzo mi spiegate che cos'era
non l'ho capita sta cosa o di recco ma
che cazzo oddio oddio no via scappa
viene addosso
credo non è che poi magari non avviene
no no viene aiuto aiuto le donne oddio
nel cesso mi butto nel cesso
non ci ora ci fosse un passaggio qui ok
forse l'ho scampata bella
ma forse non mi seguiva più oddio mi
segue
madonna che culo vieni qua che c'è una
scuola del peperoncino
no ma ha delle mani sexy veramente
fantastico cos'è la cosa più brutta che
abbia mai visto
ma oddio loro ok arriva arriva arriva
arriva riva riva telecomando ma non c'è
il buco qui mi butto nel sesso mi butto
ne tira lo sciacquone tirano aiuto se si
è incagliato oddio che alito brutto che
sta mist alitando in faccia ragazzi
credo ma che bello se le mentine servono
farne un buon uso ragazzi o giro si
avvicina aiuto no no no no no no no no
no stai lontano lontano lontano che ce
lo spray ma se lo vedevano qui dentro
qui dentro evidente
mamma mia ragazzi mammamia vieni qui
vieni a prendermi che ansia sto gioco
ragazzino veramente una cosa assurda
no no no no no no perché io sono un
idiota perché che culo do rio gere a
torino ragazzi devo stare attento sto
qui si gira facilmente allora devo
correre dove indietro indietro indietro
indietro veloce qui qui qui no qui non
ci sono andato da dov'è arrivato
ok vado vado vado vado vado a sinistra
ragazzi non solo andare prendo le strade
a caso qua dentro no ho dentro non si
portano in sé una parte qua pagina non
perdere tempo a leggere che c'è con
l'affare che ci segue
vailatti amanti mattino attivamente
destra ancora destra lo sbagliato si sta
corri cieco da fare madonna
un po a cazzo ancora ma quanti ce ne
sono
oddio via ce ne sono due ragazzi qua qua
qua qua qua qua perfetto salvo tana ok
ce ne sono due
me ne è passato uno davanti che non ho
capito da dove è spuntato però se n'è
andato dall'altra parte non ci tengo ad
andarci ok dove siamo finiti non ne ho
la più pallida idea ma meglio di del
posto di prima di sicuro ok
apri apri non si apre da qua non penso
che mi possa arrivare perchè non ok ok
ok perfetto
no non mi devo ascoltare quando parlo
entra ok faq del set
ok ragazzi è una situazione molto molto
precaria qui dobbiamo tornare indietro
non so dove ma devo tornarci alla svelta
ecco qua qua non c'è non ci sono andato
perfetto cos'è sta roba
non lo so ma non mi piace vediamo di
filarsela al più presto
ok sinistra qua si sa perché perfetto
io che bordello spegni ti disse
strumento davvero qua intanto il cavo
sta prendendo possesso del mio corpo
quindi devo togliere ok qui non non può
arrivare vero non sa salire le scale
no perché ha le mani al posto delle
gambe ok ok ok ok ok ok non sai salire
le scale vero non le sai non è invece le
sale carso dove di questo dove ok hai
visto l'hai visto
bene finché sta lì io non so dove andare
per devo andare dalla parte opposta però
è lui è sempre lì
allora facciamo così vieni vieni vieni
vieni vieni vieni ok ragazzi tentativo
di raggiro incredibile
sempre che non mi porta lui ce la
dovremmo fare vai vai vai vai vai vai
subito dentro subito dentro la porta a
pretty no è chiusa oddio no no no no no
no no no no che cattivo che sei
ragazzino naso gioco veramente un
qualcosa di tutto fuorché normale vabbè
lolo continuo spero si possa continuare
si possa salvare la partita perché lo
voglio continuare prossimo episodio
perché abbiamo già superato il tempo
limite comunque è vago
se vi è piaciuto video lasciate mi piace
anche la pagina facebook che trovate in
descrizione se non siete ancora i sinti
iscrivetevi fatemi sapere se vi piace e
noi ci vediamo prossimo episodio bella
ragazzi